this is the story of one big family I'm
Xin Engvall and this handsome daddy is
my husband bill these are our kids
PJ Bryn Barney Bancroft Becky built slow
down please and Beit Ron that's 17 kids
and all give or take but I could fit
much more in my family so I'm pregnant
again we always do we didn't want a
typical family we wanted a farm of kids
our eldest son BJ has proposed to the
love of his life Elizabeth and she said
yes it's a miracle and according to your
doctor it's also a miracle that you can
still get pregnant ah double miracle and
because Lizzie's a part of our family
now I took her out to find a wedding
dress at my favorite secondhand wedding
shop
welcome to Something Borrowed
congratulations on your love this place
is so glamorous just like Quiznos it was
a regular girls day out
and JP came to for some reason girls are
susceptible to a lot of dangers in the
outside world which is why I wanted to
come out come with Jean without
protective or protection I wanted to
come with Jean at the same time are you
guys looking for something traditional
modern train no train Oh something a
heavily discounted saving money is very
important when you have 17 kids Wow
okay come back here with me we call this
the rack of broken dreams dreams are the
only movies that I'm allowed to watch
okay
these are perfect I want to try them on
you can try them on Oh calm down this is
a store that's not special mm-hmm bring
it down it was great getting to see
Lizzie try on dresses they were so
pretty
oh no I love all the colors the greens
and the brown looks like a bruise oh
well it's very moldy because two
fishermen scooped it out of a beach
whales blowhole oh well that's very nice
I love whales Jonah but I think it's too
much cleavage I I do
modesty is important to our family if a
boy knows what your ankle looks like he
knows what your knees look like if he
knows that your knees look like he knows
what your boobs look like boobs look
like knees since he's engaged now
I thought it would be a good time to
teach BJ what being a married man is all
about love commitment and banging out
two baker's dozen of children before the
Lord comes back on a flaming sheep to
judge us all this is one of the best
tips I can give you some have a turkey
fridge keeps the energy out much-needed
protein and you'd be surprised with a
little turkey grease can do it a pinch I
get what you mean I have no idea what he
means just felt wrong come on come on
right do that Hey and this son is my
conception sheet it's the best way to
ensure your seed takes purchase hallo
you looks like my one-eyed ghost costume
yeah it looks like hmm okay this one is
real cheap you may notice a slightly
irregular sleeve also there's a big tire
track mark across the front I look just
like that raccoon I saw once actually
this is better than the skid marks we
saw on that other dress well I think you
look really nice maybe a little tired
I've heard of a track suit but a track
dress hit the brake money but you are
showing a little too much skin but it's
got this cable thing no still no okay do
you guys remember this story where the
groom threw himself into a wood chipper
no why oh oh
smells like iron it's just like my night
movies that's horrible I agree with
cousin Jamie showing way too much face I
love your face oh I like it I don't know
why I put you in that you look
terrifying back at the house I showed BJ
a special book that teaches a new
husband to be everything he needs to
know about sex it starts pretty basic
when laying with your beloved a hug is
optional but not encouraged this is
important all should take place in utter
darkness that way even God can't see
well we've already covered that oh this
one's important after the diva it's
essential that you take a scalding hot
groin bath to cleanse yourself and
remind yourself that what you did was
for family and not for pleasure just to
be clear I still put my thing in her her
other thing
yes you put your thing in and like every
good father should I took a moment to
teach BJ
how to use a condom this is a condom
this is a banana listen carefully you
take the condom you throw it away you
eat the banana the Prophet Kirk Cameron
says that a banana is proof that God
exists I don't know why but he was right
ya never do that again after a long day
of shopping we left the store
empty-handed I really would have liked
to take home the blood 117 kids damn
[ __ ] how big is your [ __ ] you could
probably wear that [ __ ] as a wedding
dress that [ __ ] so big if you need a
venue may I suggest that big-ass [ __ ]
that pussy's probably got some great
acoustics something borrowed something
blue how about that use ass bruised ass
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] that pussy's big when the
girls got home I could tell something
was wrong and when jeans upset there's
usually only one thing that can cheer
her up
honey what's wrong should I get the
turkey no I'm just so frustrated I mean
I couldn't find a dress modest enough
that is frustrating bring it in for a
squeezer I should get the turkey Oh No
when you have a family of 17 children
you know not everything comes easy from
fatherhood lessons to finding a wedding
dress thankfully I had that book and
thankfully I had to rob some bubble wrap
and some duct tape oh let's do it get
her up there good we got to make the
dress tie it up tight oh good my little
drug sneaker and she breathed can she
breathe
oh oh it's so modest
so modest daddy no no no stop
so somebody grab my football real fast
kids have I got in an air hole hello
what my dad taught me to do and that's
how you use a condom I like it